as the death toll from the coronavirus
rises we are also hearing inspiring
stories from those who have recovered
people we've interviewed describe the
debilitating symptoms and how their
treatment and support systems help them
pull through this our lead national
correspondent David bag know he's home
to talk to some of them he joins us
again from his New York City apartment
David always good to see you what did
you learn from the interviews that
there's hope happening around the
country Gail by which people are walking
out of a hospital survivors you know
it's important for us as journalists to
not only tell you where the cases are
rising but also where people are
surviving because folks have said to me
David I want to know how they were
treated and how their recovery is going
so this morning we're gonna take you to
Puerto Rico and Louisiana but we're
gonna start in Georgia clay Bentley is
sure happy to be home
he is quarantined in his bedroom after
spending 12 days in a Georgia hospital
we followed his fight against
coronavirus for more than a week there
was a point where the doctors told clay
there was really nothing more they could
do they say antibiotics through your
system and they said you in worse shape
today then you weren't when you came
into hospital it's not ten times
stronger than the flu like a hammer clay
says right about when the doctors were
going to put him on a ventilator there
were signs of improvement
he says his faith was key to his
recovery I couldn't breathe at all the
chest tightness and feeling like you
can't get your breath all the way that's
really scary Aviva Williamson of
Shreveport Louisiana was diagnosed four
days ago the 36 year old mother of four
says she's still dealing with dizziness
and fatigue I tried to keep a mindset
you know that I'm just gonna get through
it and nothing else wrong bad is gonna
happen and then there's the story of
Frank eller an 87 year old retired
Marine from San Diego who was just
released from the hospital he was in
critical condition
when he was evacuated from a cruise ship
and taken to a hospital in mayagüez
Puerto Rico
weeks ago he arrived with pneumonia and
five underlying conditions severe heart
conditions including a leaky heart valve
and even info Sima in one lung we spoke
to him from his hospital bed a week ago
at what point in the treatment progress
did you start to feel relief I would say
once they got me in this isolation room
and started getting the antibiotics in
me and the oxygen
almost immediately of course we could
not have done it without the hospital's
outstanding efforts and finally the
grace of God amen that's why I am here
mr. eller is at home this morning in San
Diego he was never on a ventilator and I
can't get over this five underlying
health conditions the emphysema in one
lung heart disease leaky heart valve
peripheral neuropathy and an irregular
heartbeat and he still survived at 87
how's that for hope to hear that David
we need to hear the stories of survival
I love the clave story because we've
been following him all over the country
to see him back home that's great I
loved all the stories actually of
everybody that survived that is and
wonderful we have an abundance of hope
here today to do indeed thank you for
contributing that reporting